just got cold feet i'm sorry that i put
you in this situation
and i'm really glad you came back so you
feeling like
marrying me into this
marriage is a big thing it's a big thing
well so
is breaking the law mike after finally
explaining to natalie why he called off
the wedding
he proposed the idea that she stays in
america past the 90 days
without them getting married and on top
of that
he thought a lawyer would tell them that
that's okay
is it terrible if we go past the 90 days
i mean it's not like they're going to
come take her out of my house right i
mean there's thousands of people here on
visas right now i don't recommend that
now they're considering getting married
just so natalie won't be in the country
illegally
i wonder how tamara feels about all of
this
she just drove six hours in one day for
them to try to work something out now
i have so many thoughts on this why
couldn't mike just stick to his decision
and let natalie go it made me ask myself
why is it so hard for us to let go of
relationships
that we know we really don't want why
we're gonna talk about it plus we're
gonna take a look at the couples who
went ahead and made the decision
to say i do oh my god
you ready
i make a flower for me
all of the weddings were beautiful but
there was one
in particular that really stood out to
me i'll tell you why
in just a few
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
this episode was so good
and no i'm not just saying that we had
natalie and mike's drama playing out
like a lifetime
movie and weddings here and there to
remind us that okay
there is still some hope for love when
it comes to this 90 day cast
but before we get into that let's take a
look at what happened when natalie found
out
she had to go back to mike's house
unfortunately i can't take cards with
another person's name on it
even he paid for it oh no
you might have to bet go back to his
house
okay
at this point it's night natalie and
mike's friend tamara are three hours
from his house
and they're pretty much out of options i
don't know their goal
what will happen to me i don't have much
money with me
i have no credit cards
[Music]
i cannot stay with tamara because she
has a full house
and there's no space for me wait wait we
have to rewind
natalie said she didn't have much money
on her and she didn't have
any credit cards where was she going
she didn't need to go anywhere what
you're about to travel across the world
during the middle of a pandemic
there's no guarantee you're gonna get
into your country and you're basically
empty-handed
that is a setup maybe it's a good thing
she got sent back to mike's house
we're here we're here when she arrived
late that night
he asked her to turn off the cameras i
assumed
that once they woke up that morning he
was gonna get into his car
drive her to seattle so she can get on
her flight to europe
but no the moment i saw natalie looking
comfortable in mike's kitchen
my reaction was the cats exactly
oh goodness she is really back mike was
happy natalie was there
look at him he was wiggling his toes and
everything
look at him these two are something else
is there any chance you think we could
sit down and talk baby yep and then he
called her baby
and she answered
talked about yesterday mike went on to
explain that he called off the wedding
because he was
nervous natalie insisted that it had to
be something else
but after mike assured her that it
wasn't there was this
moment where we could see that on top of
being hurt
natalie was also pretty embarrassed
knowing that one day
we were going to see this i got rejected
before the bridge
everybody's gonna laugh with me
so far what did they do no one's gonna
laugh at you
what did you do michael no one's gonna
lie what is my fault nothing's your
fault
i was an [ __ ]
i'm sorry that i put you in this
situation i love you very much
but i don't mean to hurt you natalie
ended up forgiving mike
which i think is only right because
let's be real here
we know why mike doesn't want to marry
natalie
she called him low class among many
other things
now i'm not saying that's any excuse for
the way he's handling the situation
but all i'm saying is that karma is real
and i think natalie knows that
at this point it's a matter of hours
before natalie's visa is up
and mike has made it clear that he wants
her to stay so the next day they called
a lawyer to weigh their options
i mean with the news and everything
going on like i've kind of seen that
they're not holding people responsible
or sending them back because of the
coronavirus
and she's worried to be illegal as she
says tomorrow
and i'm saying that she could stay
longer you will have
unlawful presence because you will not
have married and filed your paperwork
within the 90 days
if i'm not getting married to mike i'm
considered as a criminal here like i
break the law
i'm not okay with that to be honest i'm
angry to be with someone
and rely on someone who cannot make a
decision natalie
took that anger out on the lawyer who
basically told her hey sweetie
the law does not care about i understand
your feelings a totally very high stress
situation
no you don't understand he can't
salvation two hours before debating
uh i don't choose listen to her
he's been changing his mind all the time
it's not
okay i mean it's not okay with me can
you please um i don't know
suggest me what to do that's not really
a legal question
then that's a personal decision that you
need to make
well fast forward to later on that day
mike was still being indecisive
knowing that they have less than 24
hours before natalie would be breaking
the law
i couldn't even imagine someone
dangling my future in front of me like
it's a piece of fruit
mike you had 90 days and before that you
had a few years
so if you don't know now it's not it
natalie went to him nicely just asking
him to make a decision
either buy me a ticket home or tell me
you're going to marry me
and mike responded by saying that he's
still processing it
no there's no more processing anything
you know the answer you just don't want
to accept what you know
that brings more misery they say when
you know better
you do better and when you do better you
experience better
mike obviously needs to work on trusting
himself more
trusting his gut next week it looks like
natalie and mike
might really be getting married i feel
like
everything that could go wrong went
wrong
oh my god i'm not sure that michael is
going to
marry me knowing mike he probably still
isn't sure
all right let's go ahead and feel the
love in the air for a moment
julia and brandon tie the knot in a
beautiful church ceremony
brandon's grandfather was there and
julia's parents virtually attended
when it comes to the vows julia wrote
hers in english
and brandon wrote his in a russian which
brought julia to tears
yeah luploot yeah i
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god this is make me cry because
this is
so cute this is oh my god this is like
i don't explain like cute kids cute kids
they shared a number of kisses
and of course betty was emotional it was
so sweet
now ziad made sure his hair was perfect
for his big wedding day to rebecca
and although she was worried about her
dress at first she looked
lovely diet will you have rebecca
to be your wife as long as you both
shall live
i do i do and rebecca
will you have ziad to be your husband as
long as you both shall live
yeah i do this journey has been long and
hard for those two
so it was nice to see everything come
together for them
all right last but not least hazel and
tariq
this is the wedding that really stood
out to me we've seen this couple come
such a long way from hazel barely
wanting to wreak to touch her
to them now becoming man and wife
hazel was worried about her parents not
showing up virtually
but they did and besides the fact that
she looked
gorgeous her vows included tariq's
daughter
sorry i promise i'll be loyal to you
and a good wife
and a stepmom foreign
i love you both forever
and ever oh i know that meant so much to
him
all right well there is one more couple
other than mike and natalie
who haven't tied the knot yet next week
is jovi
and yara's turn so are you excited to
get married
i feel because of joey's work trip we
don't have a full 90 days to just figure
out if he wants to get married honestly
i don't know how do you think or is
doing right now
i mean i hope everything's good i'm
feeling nervous
the thought's going through my mind
right now maybe i'm not making the right
decision
only time will tell all right 90 day
fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual we are covering it all
i will see you next time
you